couple weekends ago me and the boys did
a game jam called lotum dare or ludum
dare we had 72 hours to make a game from
scratch using hazel and we live streamed
the whole thing some things went well it
works it actually works no sweet that's
a beautiful door animation while others
not so much my streamlabs obs just
crashed
i'm sorry
but somehow we managed to come up with
this game called forrest you guys can
download and play it for free using the
link in the description below we also
raised over two thousand dollars to help
people affected by the war in ukraine so
what was our weekend like what did it
take to make this game how many times
did hazel crash and was it more than
premiere pro while editing this video
glad you asked let's find out
if it is somewhat of a story driven game
a little bit or whatever there might
have to be like some
pages from a diary
that you can pick up and read i guess
that would be cool like it could be like
a puzzle game kind of like puzzle game
mixed with like we're running through
forest something's chasing us it's
getting closer and closer we can do
something to fight it off but eventually
you just can't win i think we'd also
have to procedurally generate this
obviously okay but here's the thing
right ghost we make a ghost
you know why ghosts are good because
they can go through trees and hence we
don't need pathfinding exactly and we
got started
yeah i'm kind of sad that it started at
like 3 am for me but i guess i'll have
to make do
here she is this is the future
cherno replacement please teach her rust
instead of seatbelt plus
that's funny
you can probably more or less get this
to work
there you go then you can
enter your house which looks pretty cool
and you can close the door behind you
and yeah we've basically got yeah stuff
okay let's get some feedback going for
the gun
[Music]
shooting you guys like my recoil
[Music]
i think i want to add this copy paste
transform thing because it's just such
an easy thing to add and it's going to
make everyone's life so much easier
there's like an ncs when you want to
inspect your gun
uh if you go to a transform component
you can now copy it and paste
and so and the benefit is you can
obviously do this while something's
running so like you can basically pause
it or whatever
tweak tweak whatever you want and then
instead of doing what i always do which
is saving it yeah um
taking a screenshot yeah
you can just copy it
go back here paste it
i was gonna make it now
being like
you can see it works
okay that is pretty cool i'm not gonna
lie
dude that generally
tim
this genuinely looks like sparks i was
like let's make sparks and then i just
made sparks
[Music]
um well that's not creepy at all
[Music]
cheese this can be the cheese house
you guys can be like too young go into
the cheese house he'll have no idea what
he's what you guys doing it can be our
little inside joke
can you tell that it's been like
17 hours of
streaming and
four hours of sleep in the past of like
30-ish hours
my eyes are usually the tell it's only
seven hours to do a 24-hour stream uh
the problem is i have a wedding to be at
at 10 a.m in another city and i have a
flight to catch in an hour and a half so
so maybe monday to tuesday like that's
possible
yeah i think people can hear you alright
tell me a story my story well i have
basically been implementing the ghosts
like very rudimentary kind of ghost
behavior
right um
you know if we think about it like then
i think the next step should just be
a procedural forest generation thing
where basically as you run in any
direction it just generates more and
more forest endlessly right so that's
fun maybe that's something you could
work on because i imagine that'll
actually be interesting yeah you could
basically like we could have some tree
prefabs or whatever and you could just
keep generating stuff and then i might
what i might do is take a look at some
of the graphics stuff in the engine
right so this is what's happened during
the night all these commits here at a
majority of assets before sydney
that's funny that's a lot of stuff okay
cool
damn tim made a lot of assets so yeah so
we want some transparency for the ghost
and we want some fog as well so this fog
is gonna be really simple it's basically
gonna be like what is the depth of the
pixel and then
scale that to black or to white or to
whatever that's it and by scaling i mean
lipid so we set up some goals for the
ukrainian fundraiser the first of which
for a thousand dollars is 50 push-ups
[Music]
so like if we had a factory fog color
equals let's make it like white as an
example then we could just say color
equals mix color fog color fog amount
and so now you can see we fade off to
white now why it's probably a little
strong now we kind of have a foggy thing
right the fog color we can control you
can
set it to anything so we can make it
like kind of a pink
or orange
that's scary
um but yeah or just classic black
now that we've done that let's make it
be a custom shader so you see how it
says shader up here so hazel pbr static
i want to take that i want to make a new
shader um and then that's going to be
our kind of transparent shader and that
transparent shader is going to be like
kind of like oh we have transparent
objects this means that we will render
them obviously later in the pipeline
after the opaque pass and
we will um also kind of customize that
shader probably for this game make it
kind of fun
[Music]
i mean there's no way this just works
right so yeah now i have this weird kind
of transparent thing and if i check it
we crash that's exactly what i wanted
obviously let's try switching this to
transparent oh it worked kind of not
really actually
oh that looks promising yeah so
transparency um what do we want to set
it to
even at one it looks
weird
just because of where it sits in the
pipeline so we could actually leave it
at one that might look like more of a
realistic ghost
[Music]
even though yeah this is weird because
you can only see it over geometry that
isn't also too far away hard to say if
it's a bug or a feature yeah that's
where i'm sitting at the moment that
looks really cool though
that's it i think that's that's gonna be
a wrap on the ghosts well the model will
change but the
the shader
because that looks cool
black
awesome
try this see if
we crash or not
[Music]
um
okay this is interesting
i mean this is sort of what we want but
obviously not have them beat this close
together
but yeah no they don't like eventually
they seem to kind of stop spawning five
hours later basically i have infinite
tree gem
and terrain working let's see if we can
see it we also d spawn things behind us
and this looks a lot better with like
fog enabled
yeah you can't even see it like spawning
in so i don't use like noise generation
and seeds to like place the trees right
now meaning if they get despawn and you
go back you're gonna get some different
trees
but i don't think we necessarily need to
use noise and see this for
like tree generation like i don't think
people will necessarily pay attention to
exactly how the trees
like spawn in and kind of try and
remember that because you're gonna have
ghosts chasing you and you have to pick
stuff up
so we may we might be able to just fake
it
everyone tim's back and by now we hit
our next fundraising milestone so i
turned into a human jukebox insert coin
to continue i'm never gonna give you up
never gonna let you down never gonna run
around cause he made a little too much
money to be 20 and sad if this is to end
in fire
then we should all burn together
that's the cheese house oh
the cheese
that does look like slight like sliced
is there a reason you're using comic
stands for coding yes
it's because we hit uh the two thousand
dollar milestone on our ukraine
fundraiser all right tim stop what
you're doing and come play my game
so do it with a controller because it
feels really nice you can sit in my
chair i'll i'll allow it the boss is
cheddar boys look at me we've made it go
through the gate and you'll teleport to
the other side this one
that's nice that is so smooth
because tim is doing like art or
whatever and i mean he's building the
arts always building the scene every
artist ever he's building the scene
which is important but without like
peter doing his job at the moment oh but
peter's just woken up so what's the
problem there's no problem it's getting
dark in the office and i'm getting
worried well right guys sounds like you
have a game to make yeah yeah and 16
hours and 15 minutes to do it well
considering tim apparently he's not
stopping the stream until game jam ends
yeah i think yeah okay i'm probably not
gonna do that either
wait not gonna do that as in you're not
gonna stop the stream or you're not
gonna stay up i'm not gonna stop the
stream and they actually did that tim
managed to hit 26 hours
oh excellent boys well done
i managed to actually have time to write
an original soundtrack for this game
that's what you're hearing right now
and tim has decided to give me some of
his drugs in the form of this which is
like nootropic apparently this is the
good stuff i have not had this before if
something happens to me then tim is to
blame
well this is like all looks like it's
like turmeric or something it's so
yellow okay you can open it and
this bed not get all over me that would
be funny
[Laughter]
this i knew this would happen
whoa let's see that should play when you
get killed how fun
[Music]
so i have some questions about like the
books and the papers yeah are they only
going to be in the village or should
they spawn in the forest not only in the
village only in the village okay that
simplifies a lot of stuff okay
in that case i'm basically it's almost
ready to the point where you can like
start making stuff for it um
i just have to get it so it's the idea
that you you pick it up and you then
like press like escape for an example
and you put it down or should you put it
like in your quote-unquote inventory
that doesn't exist uh no just put it
back down i think okay the only other
thing and i don't know how difficult
this could do but it would be cool if
you found the gun along the way and not
something you spawned with immediately
yeah i don't know i think we should do
that okay
this works good good
pick up the gun
do this oh yeah that's what you want to
see works
[Music]
so
i mean i could probably start working
like a main menu yeah i think so if you
push that stuff then yeah yeah i did
i almost don't think we should have this
main menu even though peter spent so
much time on it he's gonna be very upset
oh good you're back i have some bad news
we've decided to cut the main menu
you decided to cut the main menu
yes i thought it would be much better to
just fade in smoothly into the world
instead of displaying a black screen
that says start game and options and all
that stuff but we still need a way to
get to the settings menu but i i don't
want to make it escape because people
might want to pause the game and so
they'll hit escape but actually it takes
them to the settings menu and they'll
have to start again and a very stressful
merge later we had a game but yeah hope
you guys enjoyed thanks for being with
us the whole three days and uh watching
us struggle and also have a lot of fun
and build games and make music and
perform concerts for you guys as well
thank you for helping us raise this
march yeah i made a discord channel by
the way um it's called forest uh it's on
my discord server so you can discuss the
game there and if you need help or
whatever that'll be the best line of
communication have a great day everyone
i'll see you
hopefully soon goodbye love you all